for Pakistan's former prime minister
Imran Khan has been sentenced to three
years in prison the court handed down
his ruling in his absence for illegally
selling State gifts Khan's now been
arrested in the City Lahore legal
experts say the conviction may end
Khan's chances of running in elections
later this year after his arrest the
former prime minister released this
pre-recorded statement
my fellow pakistanis by the time this
message will reach you they would have
arrested me and I will be in jail I have
one request from you an appeal that you
do not sit in your homes quietly
whatever I am doing is not for myself
I'm doing it for my pakistanis and for
you for your children's better future
if you do not stand up for your rights
you'll live like slaves slaves have no
lives of their own slaves are like ants
on the ground
the supporters of Imran Khan have been
protesting against his arrest in cities
in Pakistan in Lahore people gathered
outside his home chanting support for
the former prime minister the call for
Khan's immediate release from prison
Imran Khan is a national hero who is the
symbol of unity he is the leader of this
nation he wants to save the country
today they arrested him and set an
example this is what we are doing to our
national hero
welcome is
Imran Khan support is already saying
that they're going to be out on the
streets a significant day in Pakistan's
politics
indeed a significant day in Pakistani
politics we have reports that they've
been protests in the khyberbucktown
province people are hearing the news of
course it does not go down well with
Imran Khan's supporters we have here
with us the principal spokesperson for
Imran Khan and his party the Pakistan
South Mr Roof Hassan to tell us about
the circumstances of the city what do
you know about this well I what I've
been given to understand you know that
it was a rough handling he was covered
by the black cloth you know and they
were they were bushes and there were
shops even to be dishonest you know
requires a bit of intelligence you know
so even before the verdict had been
announced you know they had already
posted a contingent of the police at his
place so they were already waited like
like they knew what was what was going
to be uh uh said in the in the in the
Judgment so the moment the Judgment was
pronounced you know they arrested him
and it was a very rough handling and one
portion greatly not only him but all the
other personal staff you know at based
at the at the at the man Park residents
you know were also taken into custody by
the police what does this do for the
party what does this do for the upcoming
elections uh obviously uh Imran Khan was
a popular age a popular leader and his
party was has defeated the joint
combined opposition so what's the way
forward what is going to be your party's
response now well uh long before Khan
was arrested today he had put together a
mechanism uh to run the party uh in case
he's arrested and we all knew that he
was going to be arrested he most of all
knew that he was going to be arrested no
as a matter of fact he was pretty
prepared to be arrested so we have a
mechanism in place and we had our first
meeting of the four committee today and
we have given out a call for peaceful
protests right across I shall share the
uh the statement that we've released you
know and you can see exactly what all is
contained in that so that poor committee
is is now going to take decisions with
consensus you know and they will they
will they will talk the way out and
keeping in mind the circumstances you
know that arise in in due course of time
thank you very much indeed uh that was
the principal spokesperson for Imran
Khan and his party uh obviously the
party leadership is now meeting the
former prime minister Mr Qureshi shama
mud Qureshi Imran Khan had said would be
leading the party so we'll have to wait
and see what kind of what kind of
protests take place and what is the way
forward for this political party but
legal experts across Pakistan say this
was done hastily there was no court
order presented at the time of the
arrest and as you heard from his
secretary and spokesperson uh the that
he was roughed up indeed which was
unwarranted back to you in Doha come
outside in Islamabad come on thank you
very much indeed
well Imran Khan's embroiled in more than
a hundred legal cases involving alleged
corruption and terrorism he says they're
all politically motivated in April last
year he was ousted in a no-confidence
vote after his Coalition Partners
deserted him six months later Pakistan's
electoral commission disqualified Khan
from running for public office for five
years citing allegedly Corrupt Practices
well Khan and thousands of supporters
then set off in a long march to
Islamabad to demand early elections he
was shot in an attempted assassination
but his attempted to arrest Khan in
March this year but those warrants were
later canceled it was arrested again in
May but Pakistan Supreme Court ruled it
illegal
well joining me now is our correspondent
Osama bin Javed Osama you have
interviewed Imam Khan on two or three
occasions you've been following in this
story but just give us a bit of context
this all seems to have begun when Khan
lost supports of his Coalition partners
and that ended in that no confidence
vote well I'll take you even a step
further back on how Imran Khan came into
Power this is in 2018 it is essentially
a recurrence of what we've seen in the
past as well where the outgoing party
accuses the military establishment of
colluding with politicians and taking
somebody out of politics and this is
what Imran Khan was accused of in 2018
by his parties he fell out of favor with
the military resulting in a
no-confidence vote although that was a
democratic movement where he was voted
out of power instead of the military
coups or people being pushed out of
power that piece in the past but Imran
Khan is adamant that all of this is
being orchestrated against him he says
everyone in this country is against him
including the military tree the
bureaucracy the Judiciary and obviously
his political force so I interviewed him
right after his release when he was
arrested the last time and he told me
that all of this is being orchestrated
so that the most popular party according
to him is taken out of politics
what is behind all this
PDM and the establishment they are
petrified of Elections why are they
petrified because every service says PTI
will get two thirds majority the moment
there are elections now to avoid
elections even before this there are 145
cases on me criminal cases a man who's
known in this country for 50 years had
never had one case criminal case so if
you understand the reasoning by what is
going on right now the establishment and
the the PDM parties then you will know
they use this as a pretext to actually
Crush PTI
we heard Imran Khan in that statement
that he pre-recorded saying that
appealing to his supporters if you don't
stand up for your rights you're going to
be like slaves he said he appealed to
people not to sit and hide in their
homes he is likely at the moment to be
in jail is there a sense from your
experience of having covered the story
and having met the man that Imran Khan
sees himself playing lesser part or a
little part in What happens in the
future in Pakistan's politics well I
think this is a question that I asked
him and he said that he's not arrogant
enough to say that there is no future of
Pakistan without Imran Khan but
according to him there is no future of
Pakistan without law Injustice and this
is something that Imran Khan Imran
Khan's appeal was amongst the masses
that his uh his anti-establishment is
somebody who's built himself is as a
newcomer in politics and that's why he
was elected into Power he had four years
to prove himself he did do some good
things but by and large he wasn't able
to fulfill most of his promises he went
after the political Rivals that he had
at that time he jailed them the former
prime minister was barred for five years
as well a fate likely to come Imran
Khan's way as well so it has all been
happening in Cycles in Pakistan where
the most pivotal role is played by
whoever is closest to Pakistan's
powerful military establishment and and
acts upon what they want them to do I
asked Imran Khan if he was given another
chance would he do things better would
he still go about all those u-turns that
he did would you still take all of the
people that he took on board who are not
aligned with what his view was and why
he was elected and he did have some
regrets but by and large he thinks that
in Pakistan The Only Way Forward should
be the rule of law and justice
I'm not that arrogant or present you
know believe that without me the country
won't survive but all I know is that my
struggle is for 27 years
and the main gist of the struggle is
that what I saw when I went as a
teenager to England that I discovered
that without rule of law countries you
know don't prosper
you don't have democracy so the key to a
a civilized society is where everyone is
equal before the law
and unfortunately Pakistan from its
beginning
has the law of the Jungle the powerful
above law
and Pope the ordinary people don't have
access to Justice and societies like
that can never Prosper the entire
developing world is poor not because of
lack of resources because they don't
have Justice
well as we heard Pakistan his party has
been saying that they are calling for
peaceful protest we're gonna have to see
how that plays out over the days and
weeks to come Osama bin Javed thank you
very much indeed